alors que certains proches certains
proches de victimes sa patiente et
d'enfin pouvoir participer à ce procès
d'autres au contraire n'en attendent
rien du tout c'est le cas de sylvie eric
pétards lors deux filles anna et marion
ont été assassinés par les terroristes
devant la terrasse du carillon le 13
novembre 2015 dans qu'en pensent les
français ce soir kata technique est allé
à leur rencontre
depuis ils pratiquent leur foi
catholique avec assiduité et leur parle
à travers la prière reportages sur des
images de renault parquet
nous sommes à blois aujourd'hui avec un
sylvie reid pétards ou sommes-nous
sylvie c'est la basilique sainte trinité
à blois et on aime bien y aller parce
que quand on vient à blois pour
différentes choses on viens toujours ici
pour se recueillir
est-ce que vous pouvez nous nous parler
de vos filles qu'elles quel genre de
fille c'est et comment
qu'est ce qu'elle aimait et bien les
filles étaient splendides normal c'était
nos filles c'est vrai qu'elles sont
elles sont très belles et puis bale
était très avenante très ouverte à tous
et elle fonce et dans tout ce qu'elle
fait ce qu'elle voulait entreprendre ma
fille malheureusement ça c'est l'état
mais
sont toujours là mon esprit et puis c
était tellement les mineurs ce
que
c'est voyez la dernière fois que j'ai vu
ma grande fille elle est menée
m'embrasser d'un groupe d à mon petit
papa chéri je t'aime voilà ça à trois
semaines après c'était fini en fait la
prière nous permet de rejoindre les
filles même si elles sont tout le temps
avec nous par la prière elle elle
participer elles sont là tous les matins
on se lève c'est on embrasse nos
fissures sur des photos oui est ce ça
veut dire quoi ça
je souhaite à personne que ça arrive
mais moi personnellement j'ai du mal à
supporter et je le fais parce que c'est
mes filles et puis voilà j'ai envie que
j'ai envie d embrasser même s'il
s'absente
je ne participe plus à rien donc ce soit
même en idées ou en réaction beau
on arrive à vivre déjà tous les deux va
se lever le matin donc bon c'est pour
nous c'est déjà pas mal
[Musique]
évidemment ce qui a choqué toute
personne qui a eu à subir d'une manière
ou d'une autre ce drame c'est le fait de
d'entrer dans une sorte d' autre
dimension le terrorisme la violence pure
qui allez vous en avez pensé quoi ça
aurait jamais dû se produire quoi il
faut réagir quoi parce que bon il ya
quand même charlie hebdo il ya des
prêtres il ya des gens à nice et plein
d'innocents et je vois pas quoi que ça
continue quoi il faudrait peut-être
quand même réagir quoi parce que à
chaque attentat on prend des mesures
patati patata puis finalement ça
recommence tout le temps quoi et
d'ailleurs vous avez décidé de ne pas
assister au procès lorsque c'est parce
que voulez vous prémunir de toute cette
date de l'énoncé cette violence ou est
ce que c'est parce que vous n'y croyez
pas tout simplement mais les deux se
prémunir parce que je pense que ça ne
nous apportera rien à nous deux a encore
tout ce tout cet étalage de deux faits
puis et puis nous on croit pas on croit
pas aux réponses aux explications qu'on
peut pourrait éventuellement avoir moi
mon procès et que ces gens devraient
déjà plus exister ça c'est sûr
et puis en fait c'est pas mon affaire le
procès de ces gens là c'est celle
affaires de l'état allal cherche des
coupables pour se faire pardonner mais
bon moi y'a rien qui passe je ne peux
pas l'accepter je donc le procès pour
moi ça amènera pas méfie d'une part et
puis en plus bas qu'est ce que vous
voulez
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je dise
que je fasse
ya rien à dire rien à faire on peut même
pas se défendre la france alors je vais
pas faire la révolution tout cela c'est
pas possible les pouvoirs publics de
l'époque qui nous en sus à l'école
militaire non c'est c'est déjà incapable
de diriger la france c'était ça c'est
sûr d'une part et en plus ils se
comportaient comme des véritables le
patin et aucune autorité rien du tout
oui monsieur oui monsieur monsieur bré
me dire ce que vous voulez non non non
je ne peux pas accepter c'est décidé
dialogue comme ça
quand il ya des temps de mort et et
d'innocents surtout tombée sur le pavé
on se comporte en homme de 1 un homme de
poigne a pas encore la valeur